Probably the most entertaining app is the comic serial app
It generates a series of comic books. Based
on your prompts here, let's say, Come
About Food parakeets. Stop
Interrupt. So. We
saved this idea. Make sure that we have models selected
These are the deep. Must be First
on the list for whatever reason. We will select. Flash
three, Gemini three flash preview
And for the image model, let's use Gemini one flash
image preview. Save our model settings. And
the reason it's called Comic serial is because you can
generate a first comic book series, comic book, which includes
many frames. We will, we will do that in a
second, but then afterwards you can generate sequels and
you can keep generating sequels as desired. The final step
is then to render the comic book into an HTML
format, which uses the same images. It just gives it
a, Nice HTML framing. But
first, we will monitor the generation of the comic book
itself. We
have a Sketch of a script. And
then it goes into character generation. The first
step that it does when generating comics is to generate
Character reference images. These are then used when it's
rendering the comics themselves. In order
to achieve. Artistic. Consistency
And now we're on to the actual page generation. Again
you can monitor this in real time. And
it ends with even a Nice little fourth wall joke
Great. So, now that that generation has completed and my
parares agree, It is time to render the comic book
This renders the HTML structure that will, How is
the comic since the, Basic comic book framing
is. Somewhat Basic. This
should only take a moment. Here
we go. Let's open this in a new tab and
preview it. We've got our character reference images and, No
A much more attractive presentation with the textual, Dialogue
alongside also. And
that is the Comic book generator. I hope you enjoy
it.